big Kansas City Chiefs fan although I
think somebody in the house is a big
Packer fan as well
she's melissa etheridge back on the
program congratulations on your Kansas
City Chiefs
[Music]
all right so set the scene yesterday
who's where are you watching it do you
need do you feel like you can jinx your
team if you're not sitting in a certain
place or wearing a certain one thing
oh no I I now think I juiced my team if
I sing the national anthem for them so I
was at home
will you buy your who's watching with
you oh it's me it's my wife it's our
oldest daughter and my youngest kids are
they're like 13 they're basically
watching me watch the game they like
they'd like to see their mother kind of
get a little crazy alright it's 17 to 7
and what are you thinking oh you know
what I'm thinking no worries because I
just saw that game last week when we
came back from 24 I was like I'm not
gonna worry ever again you got Superbowl
plans you know I don't I I don't know
yeah I really enjoy watching television
watching you know football on television
I think it's an amazing experience and I
don't know I I don't know ask me in a
week well you might want to stay away
and then I like watching it at home I
get more out of it but you know this is
this is your Chiefs I mean 50 years it's
true it's true I know and and I don't
know my head's all dizzy it's funny I
woke up and I said wow this is what it
feels like to be in the Super Bowl it's
like really crazy do you remember the
last time they were there I do like I
remember because my father was so
excited about it you know 50 years ago
and and we watched and I remember when
we won we all that the whole I was in
Leavenworth Kansas and we all just ran
out and screamed and hollered and honked
our horns and it was really fun
now your wife's a Packer fan I was like
honey I'm sorry but did you tone down
your celebration well we had we had like
a celebration for like half an hour and
then the backer started to play and then
I sort of after she went to bed I sort
of would kind of dance around then
quietly went to bed all right last time
we talked we were trying to give you
some lyrics and things that would rhyme
with mahomes and I'm sure we didn't help
out the process but do you have a Kansas
City Chiefs song for us
[Music]
this is Melissa Etheridge I got my
friends and family all blowing up my
song my kids think I've gone crazy as
I'm running around my home well I heard
that Patrick wanted me to call into his
show
well the Chiefs must have won the AFC
and we're headed to the Super Bowl when
I was just a little girl oh my that is
me I remember it like yesterday it was
1917 or that she sent it Dawson then
buck Buchanan him Bobby Bell well the
Chiefs are in the Super Bowl
I heard my daddy yeah well 50 years that
came and went and sometimes we got close
gonzales never got to go come on all the
great free stones so many times it broke
my heart thought I might never know
she's just broke that playoff curse and
now they headed to the Super Bowl
I've seen the closest man the Superman
little girl has ever known
we traded up in 17 for the greatest Pat
Mahone and now I'm never worried even if
we're far behind because the way that
number 15 plays is blowing people's
minds
now if there's anything I love as much
as California weed its Tyree Chelsea
Frank and Chris on it badger
Andy Reid so take me back to Kansas
[Music]
you're awesome you are awesome you
brought in California weed and Andy Reed
Bob Dylan is smiling somewhere
Oh a little bluesy in there yeah oh man
you killed it you killed it well thank
you for the opportunity oh I love you
thank you and good luck and if you
happen to be in Miami and you want to
stop by you let us know we'd love to see
you and I know are you out on tour still
I go I go back out on tour in the end of
March and April I'm around the East
Coast and you know come see me if I'm
near you okay well thank you Melissa we
appreciate it as always you killed it
that's wonderful thank you thank you
guys for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]